it's great to welcome to the program
today Wayne Messam Wayne is a
first-generation American a national
college football champion a successful
climate conscious business owner
two-term South Florida mayor and now
candidate for president Wayne really a
pleasure to have you on I appreciate you
being here thank you for having me so I
mean let's just start with the general
pitch that you're making for for
yourself as a presidential candidate
you're the mayor of Miramar Florida
which has I believe a population of
about a hundred and fifty thousand how
does that experience translate to being
president of a country with 330 million
people well you know being a mayor of
one of America's cities that has a
fast-growing economy we have one of the
fastest growing economy in the country
the city of Miramar we're dealing a lot
with a lot of progressive issues on in
terms of fighting gun control we
currently are suing the state of Florida
so that the city of Miramar along with
other municipalities can have a say on
gun safety in our communities because
right now we can't even discuss any of
those measures we can as a mayor I can
be removed from office by the governor
personally foul fined $5,000 and even
our city could be exposed to lawsuits so
we're fighting just for our ability to
even to discuss safety in our community
you know being the son of immigrants
coming a parents coming from Jamaica my
father was a contract sugarcane cutter
he came to this country in search of the
American dream and I'm living that
American dream went before the state to
became a national champion on the
football team of coach Bobby Bowden even
had a shot at the NFL and my NFL career
was cut short my wife and I actually
started a construction management
company so I know how to pay payroll as
well as the city of Miramar we passed a
living wage and we are actually
competing against China where our
businesses are deciding to stay and grow
in our community so with the healthy on
business environment a city that is
fighting for gun control and we're
actually even fighting to stop all
drilling
taking place right outside of the
borders of our cities in the precious
Everglades non-threatening 8 million
South Floridians water supply so we're
at the forefront of very pressing issues
that that cities across this country are
facing but Washington seems not to be
solving these challenges for Americans
but that's why I'm casting my candidacy
to be President of the United States we
want to ensure that Americans can have a
second chance of the American dream so I
want to get my audience up to speed on
your policies on a bunch of different
issues and and one of those of course
that has become sort of a litmus test on
the 2020 Democratic slate of candidates
is what you would do about health care
do you support either Medicare for all
or some other way of getting 100%
universal coverage while taking profit
out of the health insurance industry
well I believe every American should
have access to health care as a matter
of silver right there's been some
discussions about Medicare for all that
is a reform um idea that I can
definitely on support I also think
though however that an ideal world an
ideal scenario you want to be able to
have universal health care and that will
be the goal that I would fight towards I
also think though that if you have a
private insurer or if your company
provides on medical benefits for you and
you're happy with that perhaps um you
should have the ability to keep that and
those individuals who want to have a
medic can be a part of the Medicare
program with the expansion of Medicare
to cover just more than our seniors you
should have the ability to go over to
Medicare as well now just like me know
I'd be I want to be clear way now when
you say you should have that option are
you talking about a buy into Medicare
that someone would have to pay above and
beyond what they already contribute via
taxes to well I think if you're if
you're you should be able to bring what
you are paying for example if you're
paying and contributing towards your
insurance with your employer if you
decided you want to go over to Medicare
you should be able to bring over those
premiums over to help supplement on the
payment for you to be into the Medicare
program but isn't that exactly the
problem that people can't afford those
plans that they're on so
if we say hey what you're paying now
which is unaffordable just pay for bring
it over and pay for Medicare it doesn't
actually seem to get at the root of the
problem does it well the thing is if you
don't have access to health care if you
don't have access to health care there
should be a mechanism for you to get
into the Medicare program okay can't
afford the insurance that your employer
is providing for you you should be able
to go over into the Medicare program
however if you are in the position where
you're satisfied and you're happy with
your insurance program you should have
that choice to be able to stay as well
but in an ideal scenario I think because
health care should be a matter of civil
right for Americans to have Act to have
access to health care that obviously an
ideal situation a single-payer system is
the ideal situation yeah because it
seems if you're talking about something
as a right it can't be a right as long
as you transition your employer premium
over to a Medicare premium that doesn't
make it sound like a right I think too
maybe many people in my audience I'm
sure you know what I mean yeah I know
exactly what you mean
there are a lot of Americans however
they are satisfied with their insurance
program and plans that they have
obviously when you are reforming a
social service like like a
medicare-for-all program or like health
insurance young you have competing
interests you have you have Americans
themselves that may not all agree so
that's why I state that in terms of an
ideal situation you want to have a
single pair process about our program
program where everyone has access to
this health care but we know that it
will be a situation where there will be
a transition from where we are today to
get to that model and recognizing that
there will be some situations where you
have Americans who are fine where they
are but it should not have anyone being
without insurance of coverage you know
we have the Affordable Health Care Act
that's currently right now and you have
Republicans that have having a small on
that program and is doing everything
from a policy standpoint to sabotage the
success of that program so an ideal
situation we want to make sure that
every American has access to health
because it should be a matter of civil
right okay well I I agree with that last
part although it sounds like we disagree
as to how to get there let's talk about
one other issue that's become a big
topic of discussion which is what should
be done about college tuition it's
effectively undeniable that number one
the cost of college is completely
unsustainable and that number two the
college lending industry has become
completely predatory and countered to
the best interests of individuals that
want to work in fields that resonate
with them and where they feel like they
are sort of being useful people and
self-realized and self actualized what
would you do about college costs and
tuition well this is an area where I
think I have been very aggressive in
terms of all the candidates that have
come out I actually launched a plan to
address this very situation there's a
lot of discussion about the high cost of
college tuition and I think before you
even can discuss of solving that issue
you have to deal with the 1.5 trillion
dollars in outstanding student loan debt
so my plan calls for the student loan
debt forgiveness of that 1.5 trillion
dollars there's 44 million individuals
that hold that 1.5 trillion dollars in
outstanding student loan debt that's the
second largest consumer debt second only
to housing it's costing about $400 per
month and payments one out of five
student student loan holders are behind
in their premiums it's impacting our
economy and I want to forgive this debt
as an economic incentive a stimulus to
get our economy moving even more in a
positive direction all right now it's
the states that by forgiving that 1.5
trillion dollars in outstanding student
loan debt would actually add 80 to over
100 billion dollars to the GDP in the
first year it will create 1 million to
one and a half million jobs on the first
couple of years if you have debt holders
that will be able to now invest in their
futures perhaps qualified to buy their
first home or even start their own
business so we're really excited about
this program and and taking the burden
of student loan debt off of working
class and hardworking middle-class
Americans because those are the people
that actually
that loan to actually be able to pay for
their college education employers
require four-year degrees or higher you
know our economy depends on educated and
well qualified individuals so that our
economy can keep moving and I think that
that burden should not fall solely on
working class and hardworking Americans
so are you in favor of a plan like for
example Bernie Sanders plan whereby a
public college and university tuition
would be funded through taxes I
definitely think that the current the
cost of higher education is out of
control I think that we should be
looking at all types of solutions to get
that cost down in fact on we should be
investing more money into our Pell Grant
systems to provide supplemental funding
for of students that include requiring
that additional aid we should be on
supporting those states that have
stepped up to be able to offer State
College and two-year diploma programs
for free for or for their for their
students so I think that there's not
more just one solution to deal with the
current cost and moving forward but as
my plan states is that when you have 1.5
trillion dollars of outstanding debt
that is out there right now you have to
deal with that situation
in fact the CEO the CEO of chase JP
Morgan Chase stated in an op-ed that
there's a silent crisis with this some
outstanding student loan debt it's
impacting the housing market on the
financial markets and the fact of the
matter is is that I see it as a national
economic security issue but I want to
make sure to just get a clear as
possible answer because otherwise my
audience will come after me and yeah I
don't want that to happen they can get
very very angry would you be in favor or
against a plan through which taxes that
we pay would fund public colleges and
universities so students can if they get
in position free oh for sure we should
definitely using our nation's resources
in firms and for in terms of taxes to
support higher education because our
nation needs to be investing in the
American people to be educated if we are
not a
that has the ability to provide higher
education for our for our Americans we
are putting ourselves at a disadvantage
to be able to complete a globally our
domestic country companies need this
talent in this workforce to be able to
redefine and to innovate on the
solutions of not just for today before
tomorrow so I would definitely support
that but in addition to paying for
college now and moving forward I am
stressing that the 1.5 trillion dollars
right now would they stimulate the
economy it won't take the burden off of
admitting living loved hardworking
Americans that are just trying to make
ends meet so that they can be able to
have gainful lives so they can take care
of themselves and be able to achieve the
American dream on Tax Policy do you
think that the top marginal tax rates
need to go up if so to how much and at
what income level would that kick in
well I'll be releasing a plan that will
outside that will outline all of those
parameters but I do agree in principle
in terms for the richest of Americans
that have been able to exploit our tax
code and to basically have been able to
pay little to no taxes that they're not
paying their fair share on to to to to
our economy to help lift the burden off
of everyday hardworking Americans and I
would support a tax code that would
ensure that that everyone is paying
their fair share especially corporations
and the richest of Americans that have
been enjoying tax cuts after tax cuts
without paying their fair share to the
American Society okay so let's talk
strategy people who are watching and
listening will probably notice if they
look at for example the recent Emerson
poll that was released of the 2020
Democratic primary you're not in it so
what is the strategy there is a donation
require a donor requirement to make it
onto the debate stage I think you would
agree that if you don't make the debate
stage the chances of a successful
candidacy are sort of over they really
are tied in to that what's the strategy
for getting to that level
well our our campaign is they getting a
lot of attention in terms of the
proposals like in terms of our student
loan debt crisis on the requirements is
to have sixty five thousand unique
donors on coming from twenty states and
from those twenty states we should have
200 donors from those 20 states our
campaign just launched a little over two
weeks ago we already have received
contributions from 43 states we're just
pushing those numbers beyond on 200 and
working hard to get to 65,000 and for
your podcasts our listeners and viewers
they can support my campaign by going to
Wayne for america.com
and contributing as middle is one or
three dollars if you believe that you
need a progressive voice from a mayor
that has done very well in tackling
progressive issues on that I bring a
unique perspective and unique voice and
if you feel that this voice should be
heard on a debate stage that you donate
to d'Alene for america.com website so
that my voice can be heard
you can help Lane get on a debate stage
all right we have been speaking with
Wayne meso who is the mayor of Miramar
Florida he's running for president on
the Democratic side you can learn much
more about him including the policies we
talked about and others that we didn't
talk about on his website which we are
linking to Wayne really appreciate you
talking to me today thanks so much for
having me take care and talk to you all
and see you all in the debate stage